[Music]
thank you
for Asian tourists it's one of the
biggest attractions in Bangkok
the Erawan Shrine a Hindu god but a
symbol of Good Fortune for all
these days
can only watch from afar
to get any closer
is too painful
I felt like I couldn't walk past it even
through the Skywalk now I can but I'm
still scared if I have to walk on the
street even when I drive past and stop
at a red light I pray that the green
light will come quickly
King Khan was there on the night in
August 2015 when a bomb exploded
20 people were killed and 125 injured
most of the victims were tourists
including a number of Chinese Nationals
prompting the theory that they might
have been the target
now after several delays including the
pandemic the trial of the main suspects
has restarted
the problem of this case started with
the military Court the military Court
put everyone who could be a potential
witness in this case in normal course
they only allow witnesses there can be a
crucial voice in the case but questions
remain about the two accused both for
traveling on false passports Chinese
Nationals but ethnic uyghurs CCTV
footage is far from conclusive and
circumstantial evidence has been
contradictory and Confused
that didn't stop the police awarding
themselves ninety thousand dollars as a
reward for the Speedy resolution of the
crime
and even though the case has resumed a
verdict isn't expected for several years
of course we have to regard to the dry
of the weekend but at the same time we
have to give some kind of legal
protection in terms of procedure
to the defendant as well but that takes
time
the attack on the Erawan Shrine was the
worst bombing in Thai history yet seven
years on there's still no clear answer
to the question who was behind the
attack
or who were they targeting and the
victims still struggling with injuries
and memories want answers
that time of getting any closure past a
long time ago it's so long that I don't
feel like I need to know who did it but
do I want to know yes I do
that resolution seems a long way off
Tony Chang altazira Bangkok